hello and welcome to this video playing
alec
alec vs um
i could actually transpose to my d4
repertoire
and switch around a little bit
it's a bit of an uncommon move order but
i just like changed my mind
b5 c3 that's in my keep it simple d4
yeah that's a way of cheating um
i would now look that up
with the book right behind me
but i remembered that this is in the
book
okay that is very dangerous for black
but he seems to be rather relaxed about
things
okay knight c4
and then e5
i can also take here first yeah why not
okay if he
bishop takes pawn takes queen c4 right
this
is possible maybe
i have rook c1 things like that so
it's not clear that this is um
a real threat
so
like bishop e3 takes takes queen c4 rook
c1 for rook c8
it doesn't seem to win though
okay and then play pedestrian chess
cover stuff and just claim that you're
better by structure
[Music]
which is true but
still pedestrian
knight c5 was a threat and i just wanted
to
stop it by normal means now b6 is
also something that he has to worry
about
yet taking is the simple solution
and now what
b6 looks dangerous
yeah it's probably a good move
[Music]
i'm threatening rook a5 here amongst
others
and it is answered with ignorance
in some way
so um am i just playing rook f5 then no
right
queen c8 only move i guess
and then i can take a7 with the pawn was
my idea or
[Music]
anything better even
like guess not so let's take it
wow
what what is that like knight c5
or i mean b6 of course there was a
threat
but yeah i'm castling here right
here
knight d4 on
94.
i'm i'm still slightly worried about
knight c5 i wouldn't ever have
a more active way of handling this
but okay
i haven't killed him off which is a
shame
[Music]
it looked like that was possible but
this is not
the case anymore that this is a
like an automatic win somehow
fairly certain there was one but i
didn't find
it how do we how do we win this actually
knight to c6 somehow but night
92 was not a move that i was happy to
play
for sure but i didn't see a good
alternative
knight b3 maybe next
trading this would be generally useful
not ideal i did not want to retreat the
knight
a6
just taking that pawn is also a thing
rook a4 and take it
actually difficult for him to cover it
a seven pawn is just such a pain
uh a7 is hanging wow
um didn't took it didn't take it okay
oh man that is a pain this whole game is
a pain
this game is a pain
new rap song
holy moly
and now i'm not even equal oh
man that's crazy it was like plus a
million this freaking position
man wow this is a pain
i may maybe have to win it again if he
does some silly end game moves
he's on the way
man crazy
[Music]
just want to gain a bit of time on the
clock
okay
yeah it's still extremely drawish
how do we ever okay
i e4 he wants to get no
41 he wants to get rid of that pawn
g3 is just just totally dead
so can go to h3
i have to do this sometime
trying to somehow get to
to g form
check
king h4 is an execute self-made
[Music]
just still asking some questions
and i think he failed to answer them
correctly
i had to really win this game twice
and it was actually rather embarrassing
because it was so
much winning out of the opening
then there never should have been an end
game
i was really remarkably incompetent
yeah yeah i understand that he wants a
rematch like
i really did everything to convince him
to that i'm a clown
yeah i mean this is like i mean you see
the engine eval yeah
this is just an opening that this way
cannot be played and
i i really should end the game so
quickly and i didn't
do it okay e5 is strong
yeah i understand but the way it was
queen d3 was not a move that i wanted to
play
but i don't really see something very
powerful
queen c2 is more powerful
ah queen c2 is a cruncher and i now see
the point
wow i'm threatening knight d6 here
that's crazy
you know this and mate
ouch ouch
yeah that was very strong queen c2
that actually i think it probably forces
him to do something really painful like
queen d8 yeah
and then wow this position is just
completely awful i can take here next
just to take this pawn i mean
he's got no development yeah something
like that is crazy
crazy awful like this
okay queen d3 i mean it was still a
fantastic position and i
could not win this friggin thing
this and take this
[Music]
it somehow it still is it hangs on yes
somehow
and by now i was on 15 seconds yeah
knight b3 is really giving up huge
uh chunk of the advantage yeah e5 this
is a good move here
yeah you really you realize that the
moment you spot that this is
completely out and then
it looks really strong
it also makes sure that the bishop is
shut out and look at this and so on
okay so this one and now bishop d4
already was a good one he played this
i had to go back
i mean even here yeah i mean
rook b7
what on earth did happen here
knight c4 is just sloppy right
i mean it's still not
it is sloppy it's really sloppy queen b6
this is the domination movement the
bishop can go nowhere
queen can go nowhere queen c6
next and resignation basically
unbelievable and i allowed that
this
and now queen c6
uh crazy
it's still probably with if you be if
you are completely precise you should
keep the pawn but
i mean i had six seconds so
funny thing is or the sad thing whatever
you okay b4 was good
before of course
is that this is um here if he if he
plays
the check first
this is not not even equal i mean black
can try
a little bit him okay i should not lose
but
it's rather black and i mean the way
in in the game he did some weird things
this is not really necessary at all
it's not yet a problem but you should
not go h4 i think this is just like it
has no upside it just
weakens the structure
so i got this but
it's still very drawish
maybe f4 but it's still this should
always be a draw
yeah g4 that's actually true
should probably try that i did that a
little bit later
after some waiting moves
yeah it's not a surprise that black
should be able to hold but
this is this is not good right
and now this g4 move
king g6 is still okay
it's a little bit uncomfortable i should
still hold
and this way he gave away the pawn
yeah it was an odd game i had to win
twice and uh
many weird decisions okay guys thanks
for watching